two months ago today a fire tore through
notre-dame Cathedral in Paris the blaze
destroyed the Gothic roof and toppled
the famous spire there now the cathedral
is rising from the ashes notre dam is
holding its first mass since the
devastating fire you're watching live
pictures from inside the Cathedral for
safety reasons only around 30 people
mostly priests and restoration workers
are attending the mass and they are
wearing hard hats the Catholic faithful
can watch a broadcast of the mass on a
religious TV channel Joko first now
standing by for us in Paris is French
journalist on Elisabeth bootay now as we
saw I mean the Cathedral it's still
dangerous enough to require hard hats
and yet this mass is going ahead today
clearly some symbolism there I mean how
important is this moment for Paris for
Paris for Catholics for the rest of the
world I should say it's a very important
moment it's the reaffirmation of
continuation of a faith and life after
the catastrophe and your comment is just
a second ago said that the place is
still and unsafe that everyone is
wearing a hard hat including the
Archbishop of Paris more senior party
but the mass is not even in the great
names the great name is not secured yet
the masses in a chapel behind the great
nave and it's almost like a private mass
of course the public can be left in
everybody standing up because there are
no seats it's really in a situation of
catastrophe has not much work has
started yet and that's an understatement
you know this re confers the the destiny
of the faux diamond broker destined you
mean with you now today marks of course
two months since the fire do do we know
any more about how the repair works are
all proceeding
we know that not much as proceeding
because it's a very it was a very
complex fire the fire was not down in
the cathedral itself it was up in the
rafters so to speak in something called
the forest which is the the 800 year
year old beams made of oak old trunks
that held the roof together and that's
what burnt and of course the because it
lasted so long the entire Cathedral was
was was showered with burning debris and
the temperature went up to 800 degrees
so right now what they do most is
protection and assessing exactly the
condition of security the way the stones
and the rest of us we don't has
withstood such heat such long period
what is fragile where it can be kept and
that not only has there not been much
work going on but we also know perhaps
this is just a delay waiting to see what
so much of the promise money for that
rebuilding either minute and Elizabeth's
muti in Paris forests as Notre Dom
holding its first mass since that
devastating fire thank you very much
thank of course many years of
restoration and repair still lie ahead
and you might think it's all being paid
for by that flood of donations promised
by billionaires and companies after the
blaze but it turns out the church is
still waiting for much of that money DW
reporter Jared Reed has been following
up on those donations I mean Jared first
just remind us I mean how much money was
pledged for these these repairs after
the fire well after the fire there was
some pretty determined philanthropies
and we had all these rich billionaires
and companies lining up to say I'm gonna
give 100 million euros two hundred
million four hundred million and
eventually around a billion euros was
raised in a very short amount of time
which led you know created a lot of
publicity for these people also some
criticism because it looked like they
were all sort of trying to one-up each
other as you correctly say the fire
happened two months ago today and you
think that would be enough time to to
write that check or hit the send button
on the internet banking but none of
these rich donors have paid up yet
Andre for know is a spokesperson for the
not sridham in Paris this is a quote
from him the big donors haven't paid not
a cent they want to know what exactly
their money is being spent on and if
they agree to it before they hand it
over and not just to pay employees
salaries he was speaking to a P so it's
pretty incredible it seems like there
are many many strings attached to this
money of which less around 10% has been
received overall in these donations the
employees he's talking about the 150
restoration workers that are being that
are working on the cathedral at the
moment so there it there is already
being worked done right now I mean who's
picking up the check well it's it's
coming from much more humble sources
it's coming from American tourists and
French citizens they're the ones that
are donating much much smaller amounts
to organizations nonprofits involved
with the restoration work in this month
they've given around four million euros
to fund the first part of the
restoration we have to remember time is
of the essence here historians have told
us that through the centuries not
Radames been kind of neglected and after
the fire President macron gave a
timeline of five years to get this
finished
there's that plus is also a health issue
after the fire three hundred tons of
lead dust was released into the
atmosphere and so a lot of work needs to
be done to to clean that up and to do it
quickly to make the site safe for to
rebuild on so these big donors have they
responded at all to that that quote that
we heard from you
yes so some of them have come out and
said yes it's true we haven't paid the
money and that's because we want to see
what the restoration plans are and
whether they're in line with what we
think they should be and kind of what
the thinking is is that a lot of them
want their names and their money on the
end product and they're not necessarily
interested in doing kind of the boring
work of making this site clean and safe
for the restoration so we have to see
what happens over the next couple of
months and five years well we'll see if
they can hit Send on that oh thank you
God
Jared Reid thank you very much